thank you very much for joining us india
and china are both accusing the others
soldiers of firing shots in a new
confrontation
along their disputed himalayan border
china says indian troops crossed the
line of control in the western region on
monday and
opened fire and its soldiers took what
it called counter measures
but a short time ago india's military
laid the blame
with china accusing it of provocative
measures to escalate tension
both sides usually avoid firing using
firearms in the area
we'll be live with elizabeth ranum in
india's capital new delhi in just a
moment but first to katrina you
in beijing so katrina once again we have
conflicting claims from both sides about
what's happening at that border region
what is beijing saying happened in this
latest incident
that's right folly well according to
china's military this is the second time
they say that indian troops have
violated abort this border agreement
in the past two weeks now they say that
this took place in the eastern ladakh
area which is close to china's tibetan
autonomous region along this
border area and according to the chinese
side there were some chinese troops
which approached
the indian side in order to conduct
negotiations
and then they say that some indian
troops fired at the chinese side
and as a result china's military were
forced to take countermeasures
although we don't know exactly what form
those counter measures took and also we
don't know
whether there were any casualties
involved in this incident
now china has called this a serious
provocation and violation of the border
agreement we know that
things between these two sides have been
tense for some years but if this is true
this will be
one of the first times firearms had been
involved in about 40 years there had
been an agreement
to keep firearms out of it uh but we do
know that things have been escalating
with both sides building up troops
uh for the past two months staring at
times at each other eyeball to eye
eyeball along this disputed area both
sides unable to agree over this line of
actual
control which is further complicated by
this complex topography
along the region now we know firearms
have not been used but things
did escalate in june where there was a
skirmish between both sides and at least
20 indian soldiers
were lost china says that it's
conducting negotiations and dialogues
with the indian side and there have been
talks
um at different levels for the past few
weeks including very high level talk in
moscow
between both defence ministers from both
countries just
last friday but it seems that those
talks have been very limited in terms of
what progress they have been able to
make
and india also says that china has
captured five
indian civilians and china's foreign
ministry when asked about this said they
didn't have
any information uh saying simply that
they were continuing
dialogue with india that they wanted
peace but china's foreign ministry has
predictably laid the blame for
escalating tensions completely with the
indian side thank you for that katrina
you
in beijing let's go to elizabeth peranam
now
for the view from india liz is in new
delhi so as we've said liz both sides
usually avoid using firearms
and india is denying being behind this
latest escalation
hi foley the latest statement from the
indian army show is just how intractable
this latest standoff between the two
countries is
the indian army is saying that at no
point did it transgress across that line
of actual control
the unofficial border between the two
countries or resort to any aggressive
means including firing
they are saying that it was the chinese
army that tried to close in on one of
india's positions
and when they were dissuaded by their
own troops that they
fired a few rounds uh in the air
they're also saying that despite grave
provocation
that uh indian troops exercised great
restraint that they
are committed to disengagement uh to
de-escalation and that china continues
to
undertake provocative activities
to escalate and they're also saying that
the latest statement by the chinese army
about the firing is an attempt to
mislead its domestic and the
international
audience now this happened just three
days
after that meeting between the two
countries defense ministers
um at the shanghai corporation
organization summit it was the
highest level meeting between
the two countries since the current
standoff began
in may and we also had both sides saying
that the other agreed to de-escalate the
situation after that
but we have had so many rounds of talks
at different levels
since may and each time they maintain
that they are
committed to disengaging and yet we've
had more incidents including the most
serious between the two countries in
june
when those 20 indian soldiers and an
unknown number of chinese soldiers were
killed
we do have a meeting between the foreign
ministers of the two countries coming up
again
coming up rather again at that shanghai
cooperation
organization summit on thursday thank
you for that elizabeth ranum live for us
in new delhi